it's a good job that I am going to the
gym tonight this is just a big cookie
it's like a cheese ball or something
very hard and texture it's sort of like
flaky Oh coconuts
oh well no it's not as sweet maybe it
would be good if you like dunked in tea
or hot chocolate or something like that
to make it wee bit softer it's actually
really good
what was this moon cake this is from my
Taiwan right it doesn't smell
recognizable to me at all
Oh might be like a fig or something mmm
you're not dog eating it on the first
date I'm still like chewing the filling
it got stuck in my teeth this reminds me
of food we used to eat back home in
Singapore sounds like a Fig Newton but
like why not huh well I really hope this
is not a real egg this is Asian this is
like from China but China is really big
oh yeah I can see the Vice it's
definitely like a pastry type thing from
where I found we don't eat like pastries
that has like a lot of things layers of
cross I'm a tough Scots whip and I can
handle this hmm no this doesn't taste
that sweet for a dessert it just like a
giant bowl of chocolate inside that was
definitely an egg I am making a very big
mess this looks delicious
it's very beautifully done frosting and
sponge cake and fruit inside this
definitely reminds me of birthday cakes
that I've had as a child growing up in
Scotland mmm looking at green icing
oh there's marzipan in there I've never
seen mice man anywhere but inland like
marzipan are very very sweet what ice
looks rather unappetizing let's be
honest it doesn't look dessert to me
cinnamon has like a little bit fruit
smell but I can't tell what it is almost
candy it looks like a healthy toffee
because it has sesame seeds on it but it
could be yummy Oh God okay oh oh really
good hmm I like this a lot
oh I don't know I would see myself
eating
is by the beach cinnamon and gooey thing
the watermelon gave like a very
refreshing taste these were really good
desserts I feel like the US has to step
up their game oh yes